weitere unterbrechungen und wir sehen
verspricht jetzt wie es mit lena berger
[Musik]
dem tag auch von meiner seite jetzt zwei
drei tage nach der wahl wieder leichen
aus dem wahlergebnis einen klaren
auftrag ab verantwortung für die zukunft
unseres landes zu übernehmen und eine
progressive regierung zu bilden das ist
nicht nur ein besonderer moment für
unsere partei sondern auch für dieses
land erstmalig führen drei parteien
gemeinsam gespräche über die zukunft und
auch über die erneuerung unseres landes
dafür haben wir jetzt alle weichen
entsprechend gestellt haben gestern
schon gemeinsam mit der fdp vertraulich
gesprochen werden dass am freitag dann
noch einmal in größerer runde fortsetzen
zwischen grünen und der fdp um dann am
samstag unseren eigenen kleinen
parteitag zu haben wo wir alle weiteren
schritte für diese sondierungsgespräche
und für die bildung einer möglichen
regierung in die wege zu leiten auch mit
blick auf weiteres sondierungsteam und
den neueren und weiteren zeitplan und
dann am sonntag gemeinsam mit der spd am
abend ebenfalls gespräche zu führen mit
der union stehen wir auch im kontakt
aber der auftrag den wir haben ist ein
klarer auftrag für eine erneuerung in
unserem land und in diesem sinne werden
wir auch in den nächsten tagen daran
arbeiten die grundlagen für eine
progressive regierung in deutschland zu
bilden
das war einmal mal unter einem möglichen
verhandlungsführer und dann noch weiter
ausüben und
[Musik]
vielleicht bei der zweiten frage
angefangen nach sieben wochen intensiven
wahlkampf und jetzt direkten
vorbereitung für die gespräche dafür
eine neue regierung zu bilden und
verantwortung in diesem land zu
übernehmen ist der schlaf natürlich
nicht deutlich mehr geworden aber jetzt
sind die weichen dafür zu stellen
wirklich inhaltlich sich darauf zu
fokussieren wie wir eine nächste
regierung bilden können und wie ich ja
gerade deutlich gemacht habe sprechen
wir jetzt zuerst mal mit der fdp und
dann mit der spd da liegen entsprechende
nicht nur einladungen sondern genau
gesprächstermine ja auch schon vor und
die union hat uns heute eingeladen auch
zu gesprächen dann in nächster woche und
da muss man dann in die genau geplant
noch gehen
wir haben ja noch nicht mal mit der
union gesprochen wie gesagt ja sprechen
jetzt erstmal mit fdp und spd
solange wir die fahrräder die wahl
jamaika ist wir sind wie vom tisch
gesetzt um die zweite kleine wie lange
soll diese größer und ihr umgehen sind
sie entscheiden dass wir in der
regierung über
sein
fahrzeug und fuhr mit
jahr 2017 sollte sich nicht wiederholen
deswegen ist unser anspruch wirklich
jetzt zügig gespräche zu führen und auch
vertrauensvoll gespräche zu führen
deswegen auch zum gestrigen abend oder
weitere gespräche ist unsere herzliche
einladung an alle anderen parteien aber
auch an uns dass es wirklich um
vertraulichkeit stattfindet weil die
weichen die man stellen will die sind ja
wirklich große erneuerung für dieses
land das heißt auch projekte die man an
geht die man bisher in diesem land noch
nicht angegangen ist gemeinsam
auszuloten und das braucht eine
vertraulichkeit aber es bedeutet auch
dass sich sondierungen nicht über wochen
gar monate hinziehen können sondern dass
diese sanierung dann zügig vonstatten
gehen und wir haben bereits im wahlkampf
deutlich gemacht wir haben auch am
wahlabend deutlich gemacht nachdem klar
war dass die spd diese wahl gewonnen hat
dass wir zuerst gespräche mit spd und
fdp führen werden und vor allen dingen
dass wir den auftrag für eine
progressive regierung haben um dieses
land zu erneuern
aber dass wir natürlich mit allen
demokratischen parteien sprechen
das hat er wissen heute ja auch schon
deutlich gemacht am sonntag spricht
erfährt die fdp mit der spd und dann
sprechen wir grünen mit der spd
[Musik]
möglich gemacht dass die gemeinschaft
könnten also der union würden
dementsprechend ergeben das ist ein
falls dieser woche und wenn man
irgendwann einen gemeinsamen
verhandlungen einsteigt ist davon
auszugehen dass man da mit einem
gemeinsamen und gehen
zur ersten frage hatte ich ja eben schon
deutlich gemacht dass wir gerade im
sozialpolitischen bereich natürlich
große schnittmenge mit der spd haben die
spd ist der wahlsieger nach dieser
bundestagswahl und deswegen ist es für
uns auch zentral diese gespräche jetzt
zu allererste zu führen aber wir reden
wie gesagt mit allen parteien und der
zweite punkt mit blick auf spd mit fdp
und grüne haben wir am wahlabend ja auch
schon deutlich gemacht dass wir zuerst
miteinander sprechen auch vertraulich
sprechen weil zum einen dieser auftrag
an uns ist dass wir eine wirkliche
erneuerung angehen und es mit blick auf
die fdp auch bereiche gibt wo man eben
eine erneuerung gerade im
gesellschaftspolitischen bereich
gemeinsam gestalten kann und auf der
anderen seite bekanntermaßen es themen
gibt wo man doch sehr weit auseinander
steht und eben auszuloten wo man brücken
bauen kann und wo man gemeinsam dieses
land ins nicht nur 21 jahrhundert
bringen kann sondern die weichen für die
zukunft zu stellen kann das halten wir
für sinnvoll und haben das am wahlabend
auch schon deutlich gemacht
seit der eröffnung danach muss ich
leider beendet
wir hatten gestern ein gutes gespräch
und wenn ich jetzt drei sätze mehr sagen
dann ist es nicht mehr vertraulich
deswegen dieses gespräch bleibt
vertraulich sowie andere gespräche auch
vertraulich bleiben werden und wir
werden aber und das ist ja dann wenn die
sondierung richtig beginnen auch mit
unserem parteitag natürlich bei größeren
gesprächen dann entsprechend auch
deutlich machen wer daran teilnimmt wann
diese gespräche stattfinden wenn die
gespräche dann wie gesagt offiziell
beginnen und dazu kann sonst auch unser
geschäftsführer später auch noch mal was
sagen wir haben den antragsentwurf für
unseren parteitag gerade eben auch
versteckt wo unser sondierungsteam mit
zehn personen benannt wird was dann bei
größeren runden entsprechend diese
gespräche führen wird
vielen dank den achten müssen sie jetzt
finden die premiere noch mal zu schicken
so dass die dort auf dem namen
entsprechend haben und man sieht ja
eigentlich kaufen ansonsten geht nicht
er
ja
so annalena baerbock co chefin der
grünen deutlich knapper deutlich kürzer
als volker wissing generalsekretär der
fdp vorhin aber genauso gleicher duktus
gleiche
vertraulichkeit hat sie auch noch mal
klar hervorgehoben
gerd joachim von fallois in berlin
wieder wir haben wenn ich das richtig
mitbekommen haben sie korrigiere mich
sehr gerne zwei sachen gelernt erstens
am sonntag treffen sich dann die grünen
auch mit der spd nachdem sich die fdp
mit der spd trifft und nächste woche
dann mit der union aber das schien für
annalena baerbock keinen zeitdruck zu
haben haben sie's wahrgenommen
ja sie hat ja gesagt
die wahl ist klar gewonnen worden von
der spd deswegen liegt da die präferenz
das war ja von vornherein klar dass die
grünen eher richtung spd tendieren aber
das muss man wieder
relativieren denn der baden
württembergische ministerpräsident
kretschmann zum beispiel er hat gesagt
er wäre er für jamaica er hat das auch
begründet mit verlässlichkeit logisch er
regiert in einer koalition mit der cdu
in baden württemberg jetzt schon in der
zweiten legislaturperiode also da gibt
es ganz unterschiedliche meinungen aber
in der tat ich war etwas zu optimistisch
was den zeitplan angeht
die spd hat am sonntag viel zu tun erst
empfängt sie die fdp und dann die grünen
obwohl so kann ich eigentlich auch nicht
formulieren denn wir wissen ja nicht wo
es stattfindet und wer der gastgeber ist
also mit den formulierungen muss man in
diesen tagen sehr vorsichtig sein ja
jetzt nehme ich mal an von verlor sie
schlafen in diesen tagen jetzt auch
nicht besonders viel telefonieren viel
höheren fiel auf den fluren dieses ganze
prozedere wie sie es ja vorhin auch
gesagt haben und wir hier heute mittag
ja auch schon diskutiert haben ist ja
sehr ungewöhnlich die kleinen parteien
geben im zweifel das tempo und das
prozedere vor wie wird sich dann lassen
sie uns noch mal so ein bisschen in die
kristallkugel der nächsten woche schauen
wie wird sich das denn aus ihrer sicht
weiter entwickeln also wird da das tempo
so schnell zu nehmen dass man dann schon
auch montag dienstag mittwoch das erste
dreier gespräch haben wird wenn es nicht
diese woche stattgefunden hat